tout juste enrobé prêt à être séchées
emballé bientôt dévorer le moment de la
touche finale pour ses pralines et au
café quelques billes un rappel de
chocolat noir sur la chaîne pour anthony
hervé la dégustation c'est toute l'année
chaque série mon cul certaines
références que d'autres mais ça reste un
métier de gourmandise non ça rentre
aussi dans notre métier puisqu'il faut
toujours être suivre le produit et
goûter à chaque étape en confiserie en
tablette en bouche et 20 tonnes de
chocolat sont produites ici chaque année
60 % vendus pendant la période des fêtes
nous on dans notre métier de chevaux
relative vraiment le gros boom
c'est mi novembre en fin novembre début
décembre et en confectionne les
chocolats et au dernier moment et après
on les amène en boutique pour qu'il soit
vendu
au mois de décembre courant décembre et
bien sûr un pic de ventes vers le 20
décembre il y a un an du pouget racheter
l'entreprise mazet dorénavant amis il
produit aussi sa marque qu'il veut plus
novatrices on va mélanger ds d'orange
avec les clous de girofle on va faire
des mélanges des pis on va utiliser des
la verveine fraîche voilà des goûts un
petit peu plus rafraîchissant un petit
peu comme si on cuisinait les chocolats
des recettes un packaging différent pour
une gamme vendus dans des boutiques de
paris jusqu'au japon en passant par la
corée du sud a un prix certains comtés 7
euros la tablette 200 g